hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's 2021 you are currently the oldest
you've ever been
and at some point if you're watching
this you have or will try to get a ps5
good luck with that every year i look
forward at the 12 months ahead of us and
uncover the games
only available on playstation to help
you plan out what you're going to do
with your money this year
with that in mind here's every ps5
exclusive
dropping in 2021 oh and to clarify
many of these will be supported on ps4
so i'll try shout that out as we go
you ready let's do this
[Music]
the times was near god of war ragnarok
back in 2018 the god of war franchise
was reimagined
moving kratos away from greek mythology
and into the norse world
the game also refocused from a hack and
slash set piece-a-thon
into a more rounded story driven action
adventure game with rpg elements
fast forward to the end of that year and
it was voted the game of the year
beating out red dead redemption 2 no
less
kratos now a single father raises his
son the best he
can the game ends with a knife edge as
we find something else
we never knew before but i'm not gonna
spoil that right now go play it again if
you have ps plus on ps5 it's absolutely
free to play
right now you should totally do that
what i can say is that
thor is heavily name-dropped to be the
bad guy in ragnarok
and in late 2021 we are scheduled to
find out
i gotta admit i personally don't believe
god of war ragnarok will be released
this year
i really hope i'm wrong but we haven't
even seen one second of gameplay yet
which makes me think 2022 is more
realistic
no it's just a gut feeling but if
cyberpunk 2077 has taught us anything
it's not to release a game before it's
finished
have you seen destruction all stars it's
essentially a hero shooter but instead
of weapons
the all-stars have vehicles originally
intended to be a release day game
destruction all-stars has been put back
to february
2021 but get this it's gonna be free on
ps plus
for the first two months after release
ps plus gamers can download this
for free but sadly not on ps4 so be sure
to add this to your library using the
playstation app
if you don't have a ps5 yet destruction
all-stars pitch 16 contestants against
one another in vehicular combat
but here's the interesting part each car
has a different perk and abilities
we've seen cars turn invisible and
others equipped with blades that slice
opponents into pieces and should your
vehicle be wrecked you can actually
leave it
and go on foot survival rates are not
high this way
destruction all-stars arrives on
february 2nd another game pushed to 2021
is death loop releasing on may 21st on
ps5
and pc xbox players are forced to wait
one year to play this game you'll find
that as this video goes on
most games are like that for xbox
players bad times
the premise of death loop is quite
unique we play as cult
an assassin stuck in a time loop every
time he dies
he resets in the world with eight
targets to hunt down
colt uses the knowledge he learns from
each death to perfect a run and defeat
everyone in his way but wait there's
also a free moving assassin on your tail
juliana assassin versus assassin only
one can win
and the other is destined to repeat the
loop forever death loop
looks innovative i can't wait to try it
on march 19th return will be releasing
solely on ps5
a third-person science fiction shooter
with elements of psychological horror
perfect for children
okay maybe not we control celine an
astronaut who is stuck
in a time loop yep it's like death loop
but a completely different direction
each time celine passes away she is
re-awoken into the same world which
evolves constantly
fighting different ghoulish enemies we
are pulled deeper into the horror
elements
as we use alien tech there are currently
more questions than answers but with the
release date approaching more info will
be coming very very soon
i'll keep you updated to me it looks
like a cross between death stranding
and control and that sounds epic next up
eloy is back in horizon forbidden west
back in zero dawn we came for the
dinosaur robots and stayed for eloy and
her desire to understand the truth about
mankind's fate
set in the far future following the
demise of mankind small pockets of human
life have evolved to the hunter-gatherer
stage of evolution
silence is set up to be the big bad guy
this time around a former ally with a
secret agenda
eloy has vowed to keep looking for
answers as a deadly plant begins to
corrupt the land
which means for us more dino slaying as
more mechanized enemies have been
confirmed
horizon forbidden west will be releasing
on ps4 in addition to ps5
but as i'm saying this no release date
just yet when we know more i'll update
the video's description
next ratchet and clank rift apart
scheduled for the first half of 2021
this game is most definitely only
available on ps5
thanks to its focus on the crazy fast
ssd in the playstation 5.
like usual ratchet and clank find
themselves at odds with their arch
nemesis
dr nefarious but it's the dimensionator
in his possession which is the key
mechanic
rifts into other dimensions open up
constantly around the game but these
aren't mere windows in time
jumping through them and we're instantly
transported to that
new world or area the extended demo
shows ways to warp near and far and the
sheer number of weapons on offer in this
platformer
ratchet and clank rift apart could be
promising more than it can deliver
but from what we've seen this could be
mind-blowing
have you seen kina bridge of spirits
okay it's definitely not a triple a game
but it's so unique and gorgeous i had to
cover it
look at these little critters kino will
be releasing on ps5 ps4 and pc
in the first quarter of 2021 a third
person action adventure title
with a focus on magical abilities from
kina who is a young spirit guide
by the way is it kina or kenner whatever
you like the combat is fast paced with
tactical dodging and both ranged and
melee attacks
but the greatest element of all is those
rot creatures who are kind of like
lemmings or pikmin
if you've ever played those two great
games using these guys to complete tasks
looks like a great deal of fun
and i want to try it and we can
customize them too
these little rots could have their own
hats i'm sold take my money
ghost wire tokyo is a first person
action game in which tokyo has all but
been completely wiped out
i mean straight up vanished our job is
to figure out what the heck happened
the combat is said to be martial arts
focus with hand gestures unleashing
mystical abilities to capture the undead
the paranormal vibes given off by the
trailer is way more horror inspired than
i personally was expecting but i'm cool
with this
details are tough to find but we have
seen a bow in the trailer and we'll be
wielding magic with elemental focus like
fire water and electricity
so if you want to be a badass ninja
exorcist ghostwire is your jam
no release date yet on this one and the
ps4 version is not slated either
only pc and ps5 next is gran turismo 7.
i'm totally the wrong person to talk
about racing games broom broom car goes
fast
and look it looked more realistic now
the dual sensor controller will be used
to recreate road surfaces via vibrations
and sound cues
and real-time ray tracing has been
confirmed
all at 4k 60 frames per second so if you
love driving in circles
expect gran turismo 7 to appear in 2021
it's impossible to have a new
playstation console release without a
final fantasy game
and this time it's final fantasy 16.
don't be put off by that number the 16th
mainline game in the never-ending jrpg
series is nothing to do with any other
game in the series
a new setting with new characters the
world of valles thea houses six kingdoms
and thanks to an unknown force called
the blithe
tension in the land is rising we know
our tale will be focused on revenge
which likely has something to do with
the giant summons final fantasy is
renowned for
in this world one person in each kingdom
is known as a dominant
who can summon those god-like entities
just like real life
in britain the only person who can do
this is the queen there are also a ton
more playstation exclusives dropping in
2021 but they don't have enough
information
to be part of this list officially so
i'm gonna fly through them right now
stray a third-person cat adventure we're
like a feline
delivery service this one is on ps4 and
pc2
goodbye volcano high a coming-of-age
story with humanoid dinosaurs
designed to help people come to terms
with their non-binary life choices
releasing on ps4 ps5 and pc as a timed
exclusive
oddworld soulstorm is coming in spring
on ps5 ps4 and pc
once again as a timed exclusive taking
abe back to his side-scrolling routes
in a 3d environment project atheia is so
early in production it still has a
working title so this is highly unlikely
to drop in 2021 but it does look like a
third-person action-adventure title
jet the far shore is coming this year on
ps4 ps5
and pc an exploration game in the same
vein as no man's sky
this is solar ash imagine journey and
fury having a baby
and you get this coming to ps4 and pc in
2021
little devil inside is another timed
console exclusive on ps4 and ps5
but it's also on pc2 it has a solo and
cooperative mode
and is full of 19th century character
and charm
look out for it in 2021 so there we have
it all 18 games i could find that are
actively being promoted as playstation
exclusives in the year of our lord
2021. there's tons more coming in 2022
like pragmata
but let's talk about that next year
shall we so what games are you going to
play this year which do you feel are
unmissable
it's gotta be god of war right i'm adam
from playstation grenade thank you for
your time
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
[Music]
time